the Django rest framework is a flexible
toolkit for building web apis using
python Bobby Stearman teaches us course
about how to use the Django rest
framework Bobby is a senior software
engineer and has created many popular
tutorials hi everyone and welcome to
this course that I'm putting together
for free code Camp over the next hour or
so I'll be showing you everything you
need to know to build your own web API
using Django rest framework I'm Bobby
steerman from dick coding and welcome to
this course let's begin hi and welcome
to the start of this course so let's
cover this off straight away what is
Django rest framework well
it's a toolkit that allows you to build
web apis okay so think of it as a
standalone API where your clients can
make requests such as get post put
delete requests to you your API receives
this information
it validates the information and it
responds to the user that's essentially
what we're trying to do here it's very
powerful it's very popular a lot of
projects that I work on these days I use
in Django rest framework some of the
projects that I use or I work on at the
minute just use djangara's framework as
a back end and then they use a react or
a view front end so a single page
application like I said it's very
popular very powerful that's why I
decided to put this course together it
will take me about an hour to an hour
and a half to finish the course it's
made up of eight modules the first two
modules are cloning down a repository
that we've got on GitHub
and then module 3 onwards will be
um looking at building models
serializers routers and Views okay by
the end of this course we will have a
fully functional web API where we can
make
requests to and we will get responses
and in the background it'll be saving
information to a database okay each
module comes with a set of instructions
so step-by-step guides and this can all
be found on GitHub which I'll show you
in a moment or two I will be here
following along every single step of the
way like I said at the end of this
course we'll have an app that hopefully
you can then
refactor and add it to your own project
okay so let's begin
what you can see on the screen is
djangos Frameworks home page now this is
a great reference point for their
documentation it's got examples it shows
you how to install stuff
it's fantastic if ever you hit a brick
wall or a dead end this is always a good
place to start always read the docs so
I'll be referencing this a few times
throughout the course
another thing docker
this project is a Django project that's
entirely dockerized
so it stands to reason that it's a good
idea if you have Docker and Docker
compose installed on your local machine
that way when you clone everything down
you can follow along with me every
single step of the way it just makes it
a lot easier when putting a course like
this together and it negates the need
for prerequisites like Python and curl
or HTT Pi on your machine so by
installing Docker it allows you just to
keep up and be a lot
um it's a lot more fluid okay so pause
the video install Docker and come back
last link that I want to show you is
GitHub
you do not need a GitHub account to get
your hands on this code it's a public
repository if you don't have a GitHub
account click the green button here
download zip
extract the files on your local machine
and you've got the code okay so you
don't need an account however if you do
have an account you have some options of
cloning this repository and I'll show
you those in a second so the project is
called drf underscore course
it has numerous different branches main
is default that's just kind of the the
empty box if you like hasn't got much
it's the very very um Bare Bones of the
project you have a complete branch
that's the complete project
um and if you clone that down you skip
forward to the end of the course and
you've got all of the code
um I would advise you to watch the video
as is a much better way of doing a
deeper dive on drf okay and then you've
got one module or one branch for each
module so there's eight modules in the
course why do you want a module two are
set up configurations a module three
onwards is building out the app
okay so these are the directories and
the files and then you've got a readme
file Okay so
a bit of an intro so welcome to the
course it's great if you're looking to
learn drf and it's also great if you're
looking to build an API like I said it's
popular it's powerful and it really will
be a good string to your bow it does say
prerequisites of python 3.10
I do use matching case statements in
this course and it only got released in
Python 3.10 if you've got it on your
local machine great however the
containers in Docker already have python
3.10 in there so you shouldn't really
need them I'll also I go on to say that
um you it's handy to make calls to the
API to have curl or HTTP installed on
your machine so you can make calls but
again I've got containers built in this
project
with it all loaded up so you don't need
to install anything so that's why I say
install Docker okay let's get started
when we clone this down we want to clone
it down into a directory and your local
machine
called drf underscore course that is our
root directory I reference it a lot
throughout the course so please call it
by that name don't call it Bobby's
course Billy's course
call it drf underscore course it just
makes our life a lot easier I've already
got one on my machine and my text editor
which in this case is vs code is already
open in that directory okay so I've
skipped that part but if you can open up
this directory
and then take the Clone code from here
I have an SSH key you can use this
GitHub CLI if you have it or a https
option I have an SSH key so I'll be
using that and lastly before I open up
vs code
um
each of these modules are recorded
individually as well on my own YouTube
channel
so if you like this course and you like
this content then I advise having a look
at the code in Channel and the playlists
on there because like I said if you like
this content you'll probably like the
other content that I put out there so
that's that I've copied over my git
clone command let's open up vs code as
you can see here let's make it a bit
bigger
I've got drf course here and it's a live
instance of my vs code so new terminal
right click that in there the little
full stop at the end here will clone it
down into drf
I have a passphrase so I'll bot that in
there
and there we have it
great so what I like about vs code is
especially when you're coding in Python
and do Django apps
um vs code has a whole bunch of
extensions that make it act like an IDE
um and it's very very good when you're
using python so
um I would strongly advise that you get
installed in your machine if you're
following along and also
the reason I'm using markdown language
um for the steps is in vs code it has a
preview option so you can actually
preview that markdown and it renders it
like it would in a web page so
this is what we get we get a directory
called back end and we get a directory
called steps and then we have a git
ignore we have a Docker compose file
which we need before firing up the
project we have a template EnV a readme
file and a server py don't worry about
server P Wi-Fi one of the containers
that we're building in Docker is
actually a flask app and it allows us to
just to fire up another application and
make requests to the API and the reason
I'm using flask is because it's it's a
lot easier to set up a Docker container
using flask than it is Django in this
instance
so let's not worry about that too much
now let's go ahead and open up module
one steps and open it up as a preview
and I'm hoping that's going to look okay
on the screen
I'm going to close my terminal for now
there we go so
I'll say this now and not throughout the
course each module has a start a middle
and an end the start will show you what
your config your directory configuration
should look like
where your files are how they're
configured when I watched previous
courses to this years and years and
years ago I found that I'll be following
along and I'll be saving files in the
wrong directories and the wrong the
directory to be called something
slightly different
I've tried to be as thorough as possible
this is what your directory should look
like at this present moment in time and
at the end of the far right at the
bottom here this is what it should like
look like at the end of the module
hopefully that's going to be helpful for
you
in the middle part of the module is the
instructions and the walk the step by
steps that I'll be walking along with
you so look we've got a back-end
directory a steps directory and a few
files so we're good to go if you
ever in doubt
um and you've cloned this down from git
and you can change and pull down the
code from the module Branch as and when
and that should reconfigure things for
you
okay steps commands
you should now have a director called Dr
of course in your development directory
this will be known as your root
directory in this module we will be
starting our project to-do list we need
to create a virtual environment now
this is dockerized we don't necessarily
need the virtual environment when we've
got dockerize project however I do
reference some bits and pieces in the
rest framework directory that we're
installing now that's all installed in
Docker but it's handy to have the
virtual environment in the project also
so I can open up those files so just
bear with me so first thing we want to
do you want to invoke this command this
python command
and we'll open it our terminal
make sure you're in the root directory
and we're creating a virtual environment
and we're calling it venv I'm on a
Windows machine so to fire up that
virtual environment I use this command
here
okay and how do I know it's running I've
got V and V and brackets there can you
see that
now we can go ahead and we can install
all the dependencies of the project
I want this to be more about Django rest
framework rather than uh Python and pip
and Django so I've already created a
requirements file which is in backend
which is here it looks like this now
when we run the following command it
will cycle through these and install
them into our virtual environment okay
so go back to the module
and we will take this command pip
install
and we'll point it towards the
requirements file in back end and it
Cycles through and it'll install
everything now you can see one of the
things we're installing is Django rest
framework djangos framework Json API and
Django fillers they're all working
together in this project okay
uh We've also got python.env this allows
us to identify environment variables in
a file in the project
and that way we can have secrets and API
keys and things like that
in here okay and this is the this is the
file that we'll be using for that okay
this that will command at the bottom
here the bit in the yellow is saying
uh-oh you need to upgrade pip you can do
that it's not necessary really but let's
go ahead and do that
paste that and that should go ahead and
then
that'll update pip and you won't see
that problem anymore
good right let's go back to module one
it's a lot easier when I'm
um not
mirroring my screen because my text is
far bigger so I don't get to see as much
so
um we've installed everything right
now we've installed Django that's the
most important one actually in this
instance
um
Django 4.1.3 okay so that's the version
of Django that we've got installed by
installing it we now have access to the
Django commands and Django admin
commands one of those commands we're
going to use is start project Okay so
we use Django admin start project I
don't want to dwell too much on this
because it's not a Django course it's a
Django rest framework course
um
there we go
what we're doing we're starting a
project and we're dumping it in back in
we should now see this drf course on the
left-hand side here
good
secrets we want to copy the template
that comes with the course and we want
to call it dot EnV so we now have this
file here
and this will be picked up in the Django
project so it's looking for a secret
Keys looking for a loud hosts okay but
it's already pre-configured you don't
want to worry too much about that
and that when I say module one and two
is all about setup that really is okay
so our configuration in module one let's
close this should now look like this
we've got back end we've got a new drf
course which is here you see that we've
got an init file we've got aski whiskey
URLs and settings okay that comes
straight out of the box when you set up
a Django project
we've got a new directory called virtual
EMV or venv
if I open that up it's got include
living scripts in lib we'll have site
packages and if you look in here this is
everything that we just installed
we've installed Django rest framework
loads of other stuff but Django West
framework is really the heart of this
course okay if you go in here we've got
files such as serializers so we'll be in
we'll be um importing this in similar
projects some of these classes methods
we'll be calling quite a lot in this
course so we'll become familiar with
this setup
soon enough okay but that is the end of
module one
what we'll do is we will have a quick
sneak peek here of module two so we'll
close this
we're going to steps module two and the
next module we will be
uh we'll be setting up a new app called
core and we'll be adding some bits and
pieces to the settings file okay
so that's module one see you in the next
module
okay it's in module two
um
what we're going to be doing is having a
look at this module 2 which is in the
steps directory we'll open it up and
we'll open it up as a preview and as I
said in the last module
these files are broken down as the top
middle and the bottom the top the bottom
show you the configuration start and
finish and a bit in the middle is all
about following steps that we can follow
along together
I know that this is correct because I
just completed it in module one just
make make sure that your configuration
is where it looks or what it looks like
on the screen
before moving on and if not just pull
down from get
okay so Django makes it easier to build
better web apps more quickly with less
code that's why I love Django so much
right so in this module we'll be
creating a Django app
a Django app is a python package that is
specifically intended for use in Django
projects an application may use common
Django conventions and it's normally all
bundled up right so we're going to
create two apps in this project one of
them is going to be called core the
other one will be called e-commerce we
won't bother ourselves with e-commerce
just yet let's focus on course so this
app will hold logic around core
functions of the app in this case it's
going to be a contact us model
serializer and view so a user can
buy some information at us at an
endpoint we'll take that information and
we'll save into the database in this
instance it will be a username
an email
sorry username a first and last name an
email and a message okay we'll store
that in the database which is quite
helpful stuff okay
what we want is python manage.pystar app
core that's the command we're going to
be using but you need to be in the back
end directory it won't work in drf
course because we're calling the
manage.py file which is in here okay so
CD
back end and then we'll add that command
here and it should start a new app
called core you see that
we now have access to it however we do
need to tell Django that that core is
active so we need to change some bits in
the settings file
so let's take this code
because I want to glance too much over
them um the the
steps but I don't also don't want to
read it straight from the screen so we
need to change some settings okay so
there's kind of three report parts we
need to change first thing we need to do
is change the Imports at the top of the
screen so that we can actually access
EnV or environment variables we're using
python.env for that and we just need to
invoke
instantiate it so we have access to it
so if we open up Django so drf course
and then go into settings.py this
settings file has been constructed
straight from Django okay so it's got no
changes in there at all you want to
change this first line or line 13 and
everything above it and just paste in
what I've just copied from the module
we've still got the path
except now we're importing dot EnV we're
importing operating system which is a
python package and now we're
instantiating dot EnV with load.env okay
it's not drf stuff but it's just it's
really helpful so we can store
information outside of the settings
next thing we want to do we want to
change secret key debug and allowed
hosts so go back in
steps pick this up
and drop it over this hit and what
that's now doing is rather than looking
at the secret key that comes straight
out of the box it's looking at the
secret key in the EnV file debug out of
the EMF file any allowed hosts out of
the Envy which are these here okay great
stuff you're all with me
next we need to tell Django that we want
to use the core app that we've just
created but also we want to use
Django extensions which is a great
package that you can install into a
project
we're going to be using Django filters
and rest framework rest framework and
Django filters work together
rest framework gives us access to all of
the view sets the serializers the
routers and things like that so
essentially you add it installed apps so
we can actually use Django rest
framework in the project so we want to
copy this
and we'll drop that directly in
installed apps okay
Django extensions again it's not drf but
you have a load of model abstracts on
watch module abstracts and that we can
just use in our models in a project to
allow us to have loads of fields without
having to code it up and it just speeds
things up
good next we need to add some specific
Django rest framework
variables
go to the bottom of the settings file so
pick it up from the steps file and drop
it in here okay
so what are we creating here creating a
variable called rest framework so Django
rest framework is looking for this
variable in the settings file okay
um
this is taken straight from
djangosframework.org
and it's kind of a basic setup it uh
lets it it's a load of key value pairs
in a dictionary and it just adds some
settings some bespoke settings to the
instance of Django rest framework that
we're playing with one project might
want token authentication might want but
another one might want page Nation
things like that
okay so these you can see we've got
exception handlers we've got default
pass classes renderer classes
what we got we've got test request
default format so when we run some test
later this is the default format of the
data that is being sent
okay and we'll add to this throughout
the course so we will be doing some
token authentication in this course
you'd be pleased to know I think that's
in module five
um and yeah okay they are the settings
URLs okay so
um normally when you're working with a
Django project you get do you do these
things in a certain order so you install
the packages change your settings add
the URLs to the URL conf because some of
the packages require that and then you
go about and you create apps models
forms
views URLs okay in that kind of order so
we'll go through that but this is the
URL conf
and what we're going to do there is
we're going to add this to urls
straight out the box IT wires up admin
we're not going to change that because
it's handy to have access to the
built-in admin page in this course so
we'll keep it as it is but instead what
we're now brought in is two things so
we've got rest framework import routers
think of a router in general Django rest
framework as a way of directing routing
traffic to your API to the correct view
okay that's what we're doing there so
when a request comes into an endpoint
that we specify the router will help to
direct that towards the view
it's uh it works well with the URL
patterns that Django uses okay so that's
why we're bringing this in here you can
write a bespoke router
um but the default route will um for
instance if we're doing a retrieve call
in a um a view set it will already know
to look for the primary key okay so you
can have a bespoke router that will look
for
um type and key but you need to write
that we're not doing that in this course
but that is where you would you would
handle that kind of logic
okay migrations lastly uh we now need to
migrate everything to a database now we
are using
um the straight out of the box database
we're not happy we haven't got a
postgresql database or anything in this
course so by running migrate and make
migrations and migrate we'll be creating
a database file essentially and that
will appear in the project so let's go
ahead and use these two commands
got a terminal you see that we're in the
correct fight um we're in the correct
directory back end
and we click migrate
that's exactly what we're expecting to
see
in Django
um in the installed apps certain things
here like auth and content types and
sessions that have database tables now
um we will be using auth especially we
need those tables in our database so we
run those migrations and migrate those
tables into this this is our temporary
database this is not production ready
database or anything like that but this
is what we'll be using so we've just
done that
and
we can now run a local server
so we'll do that quickly we are going to
use Docker in another module but right
now let's just fire up the server can
you see that
and that will say everything's looking
good and if we open up my browser
and go to 127
and what could just paste it in there
oh that's not what I wanted to apologize
one second
I think localhost should work
yeah there we go it does work so this is
exactly what we want to see at this
point it means we have configured things
exactly where we need them to be to see
um the web API in our browser you can
see that we've got no endpoints at all
but the uh the built-in home page if you
like and it's just a basic get request
and that's why you're looking at this
page okay so in the next module we will
start building out our core app so we'll
build some models serializer some views
and routers so that we can actually make
a call to an endpoint and make it all
work good
where are we so that is module two
thank you very much and I'll see you in
module three
okay module three let's begin I will
just close down some of the bits from
the last module let's go to steps module
three and we're going to preview
good so module one and two was all about
setup and config okay arguably you could
skip to this point if you're really good
at Django and you know what you're doing
you can start here you know it's a basic
setup
so
start and end so the start configuration
should look something like this the
directory configuration we've got a core
wrap in back end which is good we've got
that
Straight Out of the Box stuff nothing
fancy pants in there got a Docker Docker
file don't worry about that
got drf we've got a DBS girl light file
which we have we've got it here
um that's a new file and then we've got
everything else that we had so we're all
good to go we don't need to change
anything but if you you know lost track
a little bit you can pull down for
module three from GitHub good to go
right
in the last module we can uh we wired up
two got one new app should I say it's a
typo
what we now need to do is
um
we need to create a contact us endpoint
so a user can send their name email a
message to our back end what we need is
a module
this is a Django convention so we create
a module which translates to an SQL
table
with Fields okay okay we need a router
to direct traffic to the endpoint to a
view and then we need a serializer
to serialize data so I think a
serializer is similar to a Django form
so it does a lot less heavy lifting so a
serializer is kind of a a piece of code
that sits between a request coming in
and the back end now it serializes let's
say Json data into python data types and
then back again so it receives
information
Alters that information into something a
python can read validates it does stuff
in the background and then it spits it
back to the user that's what the
serializer is doing very similar to a
form right so that's what we need to
write and then we have a view the view
handles all of the logic this will be a
view set
or a API view an API view is very
similar to a normal Django class based
view
um but you with djangos framework they
have some other views that we can use as
well like API View
view sets and some built-in mix-ins that
we can use as well okay
so let's start with models when we do
models first so pick up the code that
you can see on the screen here
copy it go into core kind of models Ctrl
a control V okay and then save
it will have a dodgy import don't worry
about that we'll cover that up in a
second but essentially we're importing
models from Django and we've got some
extensions so remember Django extensions
give us some abstract models that we can
use a timestamp model gives us a couple
of fields like created
an activator model will give us a status
field and uh
activate a date and a deactivated date
and also we'll have a title description
model that gives us a character field or
two character Fields text field
and the reason I'm adding those is
because
um the first name and the message will
be a character field and a text field
all we need to do is just direct the
serializer to the correct field
and that's why I wanted to add it into
the course then we've got a model called
contact with inheriting some bits and
pieces here including an abstract called
model each of the tables in this course
will have a uuid as an ID field
we'll create that in a second got a meta
class and then we're adding an email
build so this is just the models.email
field all right so this is this is what
we'll be adding to the serializer also
and then we've got to done the string
method here which is a string
representation of the model again we
don't need to do a deep dive on this
this is a jungle Django model and this
is what the database will have in it
that's construct that's abstract so
abstract models you will notice that
we're importing an abstract model I've
already spoken about that we're going to
have a ideal ID field in each of our
models with a uuid field so copy this
here
in backend if you want a new directory
so we'll call this utils
within that we want a new file called
Thunder in it
Dot py
and then another file in there called
model abstracts
Dot py
and dump all of that code in there paste
okay bringing in uuid from a python
that's a built-in python package and
then models and all we're doing here is
we're creating this class called Model
it has an ID field which is a primary
key
okay so we we're using that primary key
when we're making calls to the API
and then
in the class meta we're calling it we're
saying abstracting equals true which
means we can then inherit that in our in
our contact again let's not dwell on
that too much okay good serialize this
remember serializer is some code that
sits between a user request and the back
end and back again so it handles the
serialization of information data okay
so we need to create a file in our
project called serializers.py
in call new file
okay and then in there
paste in this code what are we doing
we are importing our model that we just
created for it's it's relative that's
what is this dot is here
we're bringing in serializers so let me
touch on this quickly so when from rest
framework
import serializers what are we doing
there we are importing from our virtual
environment in this case
we're looking for rest framework and
we're looking for filing here called
serializers Now by importing that we now
have access to all of this okay so in
here we have the base serializer which
will be abstract
let's minimize some of this
so when we um when we create serializer
and we inherit serialize it's got
serializer It's this class that we'll be
using okay
so you can see here we've got a default
error message we've got Fields so it's
doing a lot of hard work there
another thing we've got is a model
serializer so a model serializer is just
a regular serializer except that a set
of default fields are automatically
populated so it links to a model
it's model serializer okay so serializer
field mapping so this is the logic where
if you've got a a serializer filled it
Maps it to a model field
but this is the reason I'm showing you
this is because this is what we're we're
importing so a lot of courses you see
online it won't really do a deep dive on
this sort of thing you know this import
serializes from serializers
um what does that mean what are we
actually using so I'm just showing you
that this is what we're doing okay so
when we create a serializer we're
inheriting from these classes so we have
access to all of the methods and
functionality Within
good
and then yeah from framework.fields
We're accessing child film and email
field
okay they're the two fields that we're
playing around with Okay so let's create
a contact serializer we're inheriting
model serializer remember this does the
map into the fields
we have a name message and email field
very similar to Django forms okay so you
add a variable and then you say what
field type it is what um widget you're
going to use this is very very similar
except in this name if you remember
we're using a
um uh Django extensions field called
title description now that gives us a
field called title
but in the serializer we want to call it
name so what we do is we point this
towards the title field okay that's why
we've got Source equals that's what that
keyword is doing and we're saying
required through so we're expecting that
information to come through from the
client if we don't it will get a 404
response same again for message we're
pointing it to description and email
where we know that's an email field
right so we've got an email field called
email in the model we have a class meta
and in there you direct it to the model
that we're looking for and then the
fields that we want that's it that's all
we need for the serializer okay we're
linking the serializer to a model that
we have all we now need to do is wire up
some views
save
talking of views let's take this code
copy go into views in call
paste that in and we'll save that okay
so
um from Jason which is a python package
bring in a Json decoder error we're
bringing in a Json response from a
Django package then from dot serializers
which we just created we're bringing in
the serializer and a few bits and pieces
from rest Frameworks we've got passes
this allows us to handle the passing of
the Json that we're going to be
receiving from the client and we've got
views so there's a whole bunch of
different views that we can handle
let's have a look the owner views here
we're using an API view in this instance
now an API view is very similar to a
Django class based View
in a way you can have a get method a
post method so on and so forth so
they're really really helpful if you've
been working with Django for a long time
it's a good nice easy transition to use
API views but you have other bits and
pieces in here as well that you can also
use
good and then you've got status so
status gives us access to a whole bunch
of predefined statuses that are in
um rest framework
so HTTP uh 200 equals 200 and we use
that in the responses that we feed back
to the client
okay so contact API view passing through
views.api view which is
it this no sorry got too much open is
this it this is what we're passing
through Okay so we've got a deep we've
got schema
we've got as View
Okay so
remember is that like a class-based view
and if you're going to render that to a
web page in Django you would use a DOT
as View at the end of it if with a
function based view you don't need to do
that
um we've got some other methods here
that we've got we won't go in it's not a
DVD dive this is a very sort of top
level
um so we've got a get serializer context
method
and we've got a get serializer method
um and at the top here in an API view
you need to put a serializer class so
the serializer class in this instance is
a contact serializer so we'll be using
these two methods here to handle the
getting of that serializer in an API
view so we now have access to that
serializer
and anyway we've then got what's the
most important part of this view it's
the post request
so what we're doing here is we are
expecting some Json to be sent in from a
client first thing we want to do is to
pass that Json using a the parser that's
built into the Django rest framework we
then use this we send that data through
to the serializer to handle the
serialization of information remember
pointed to the right Fields And if the
information that's coming in is valid
I.E there was a name a message and an
email and the email is an email type
data type and it will be valid same as a
form no different then what you do is
you save the serializer like you would a
Django form and it saves that
information to the database what you
then do is you send a response back to
the front end which is the data from the
serializer
send information in serializer takes the
information checks it validates it saves
it to the database sends the information
back okay that's what we're doing in
this post
method
if it's not
if there's an error then we spit back a
400 bad requests we know in
it's not in views we know in status
where is it there
that 400 is bad request and it will spit
back at 400 okay
and then if the encoding of the jet if
it doesn't come in as a proper Json
um then the decoder will fail and we'll
send back a status 400 with an error
message as well okay so we're handling
the information coming in in this post
request
via review same as you would in a view
in Django okay but now what we need is a
router
to root the traffic from the endpoint to
The View
so what we need is
and previous courses I would have put a
URLs or a router file in here but we're
just using it from the um the drf course
so the URL
that conf file so okay we've just added
that so uh We've imported what's
different we've imported the course
views that we just created and we've
added a new path to URL patterns now
this is a this is a API view
um again like a class based view that's
why we've got the as view at the end
um endpoint is contact and it's called
views contact view so it's very similar
to a URL pattern that we'd normally use
in Django anyway so this is why it's so
easy to kind of get your head around if
you're good at Django and that's the
Euro that's the that's the router
I think
no
what do we do when we create models
in Django we register them so we can
access them in a built-in admin page so
if you're going to admin.py
and save this code it will give us it'll
register contact to the admin page and
gives access to any instance that is
saved to the database
last thing we want to do is migrate the
changes so we've got it in a database
doing that
filling that one let's go to CD back end
maybe you need to be in back end to it
invoke the manage.py file
no more domain Django filters uh right
okay no module the reason that's done
that is because we have not got a
virtual environment you see that in the
bottom left there's no Open Bracket EnV
so
what I need to do is v e and V
backslash scripts next slash activate
dot bat because I'm on a Windows machine
CD back in the back end and then use
those same pieces of code again
there we go
good we now have you see we've migrated
contact
and uh we might so we create a migration
file and we've migrated to the database
so by running those commands we've
created this file here and you can see
we're creating a model called contact
with all of these fields so we've got ID
which is a uuid field created modified
title description so you have one line
of code in models here
because we're inheriting all of this
it actually creates a whole bunch of
other fields which is it and then we've
migrated it to the database good
now we are in a position
to
um make a call to the data make a call
to the API so what we'll do is we will
deactivate
oh
just deactivate your virtual environment
when you're doing this
we were CD one so we're in drf course
and now what we want to do is we want to
fire up Docker so you go Docker compose
up
SD dash dash build what that would do
that will call
that'll call this file here whilst
that's just doing what it needs to do I
just show you what that what's in there
we're creating two containers okay so
the API this is the Django app and
another app which is a flask app which
is a really really small lightweight
container that has curl HTT Pi installed
which will allow us to make a HTTP
request for the API
httpi sorry HTT Pi is very similar to
curl except the response you get is
really really easy on the eye
um and it's it's much it's just better I
find it better than just a normal curl
request
now Docker should be
running Happy Days
um look at the app
sorry that's a bit small
there we go this is the app so this is
flask
and then I have to be doing a lot of
zooming
and then we've got the API
there we go which is very similar to
what you'd be seeing if this was running
is in your local terminal okay so that's
working perfectly well I'm really happy
with that so we're going to app and open
up the CLI which is the equivalent is a
command line interface it's the same as
your terminal it says we have access to
http
so what I'll do
I'll go back into module three
and I will
where is it where is it where is it we
will make this this call
so what is this HTTP that is the um
that's how you invoke a call using HTTP
similar to Carl we give it the end point
in this case API is the name of the um
host
for the Django project before it had
been localhost or 127.0.0
the um
8000 is the port no different if it was
localhost 8000 it's just when you're in
Docker in this course you'll be using
API
we pass through a name message
and email they're the three fields
copy this
back in Docker paste it there
and then press enter
and you can see that it's I can't I'm
zoomed in so I haven't got access you
can see the Json at the bottom there
that is the response we're getting from
the API so it's saying that it's
actually created an entry in our
database with an ID of 881896
so that tells me it's worked now I can
demonstrate that it's worked by logging
into the admin page but I won't in this
module
perfect that is exactly where I want it
to be at the end of this module we've
got a new configuration of what a
directory should look like on the
left-hand side here but we're not going
to look at that so don't worry
but please double check before you move
on to the next module so thank you very
much
and I'll see you in module four
okay module four
Let's uh sorry I'm recording this as one
here I'm not editing at all so
um all of these screens are open because
they were open a second ago so module
four let me just tidy things up in my
screen right there we go module four go
into preview
this is what it should look like pause
have a check I'm not going to spend too
long on that on that clone down if you
need to make sure your directory setup
is the same as what it is on my screen
so in the last module we built a contact
endpoint now we want to do some tests
okay a and an app of that tests is
broken by Design I forgot you said that
it's on the Django website but it's very
much true if you don't have tests in
your app then you know you're not going
anywhere with it so what we'll do we'll
pick up all of these test cases that are
pre-written
and I'll copy them and I'll go into
backend core open up the test.py file
and drop them in
so if you're used to writing Django
tests what you'd normally do is you'd
use um you'd write some unit tests
um and you test different methods and
Views and things like that well in rest
framework you have something called an
API client well that constructs a client
similar to HTT Pi or the container in
Docker to make a call to the back end
this is just a built-in rest framework
API client that allows us to make post
put get delete requests so that's what
we're bringing in there
we've also got API test case Okay so
we're bringing in those
the contact test case inherits from API
test case and it's very similar to the
Django test cases
um you need a setup method which
constructs things in the test database
and then you can make calls against them
okay and then again we're bringing in
status like we did in the view so
um we're going to do
assert equals against some of these
tests that we're constructing and we're
expecting 200s 400s 44s and things like
that so if you use the Django these are
just pretty normal Django tests but
because we're using rest API or djangos
framework API test cases that will spend
a little bit of time going through this
no more than a few minutes so there's a
setup method
we're calling self.client the API client
okay so we can access the API client by
self.client in the methods themselves or
in the test cases we create a dictionary
here python dictionary called self.data
and we add a name message in an email
field this is what we're expecting from
the contact endpoint and then a URL
which is self.url equals contact
okay so let me minimize some of these
now it's important to note that we we
can um we can call these when we run
python python manage.py test or it's
that's already built into the docker
instance so when we fire up Docker it
automatically finds these tests and it
runs them
so we've got what eight test cases here
so we test the end point
we test the create and sorry the contact
endpoint without a name
we test the contact when name equals
blank and then we do similar to the
message
and we do similar to email except with
the email what we also then do is we do
send an email but we send a data type
that isn't an email so it'd be like a
string without an at symbol in it so
that's quite thorough test cases for
just single endpoints we've got eight
tests
first one is we sorry that's not the
first one
the first one is we get the data
from self data the response is
self.client so this is the same as
requests actually you say response equal
requests dot post very similar to that
in this in this case it's
request.client.post you pass through the
URL and then you pass through the data
which is in this case that what we're
expecting I would expect HTTP 200 okay
which is a 200 response I would also
expect that a database has one entry in
it and I'd also expect
that that database entry title is Billy
Smith because that is what's in here
okay
next I won't go through each of these
because I'm sure you understand testing
what I do I take the data and I use the
dictionary method pop to remove name so
now we've got a dictionary without a key
value name
post it I expected to say 400 because
we're expecting name it hasn't got one
again rather than popping it completely
I remove name and just add a blank
string instead and expecting 400 so
these last seven test cases I'm
expecting four hundreds okay
so that's testing
go back in the module what we can then
do is we can use this command python
manage.py in docker
but this time we want to go into API
container
does the app container I apologize
go back in here go into CLI
changes I make locally
will work in Docker because I'm using
something called volumes so it persists
data so essentially what happens outside
of Docker in my project will also be in
the docker container
so those test cases will now be there
should be
there we go so it's run eight tests
we've created eight tests they're all
okay so every time we're looking for 200
bang on every time a 400 perfect so now
what we can do is
um oh we've all we've already done this
we've already done this
as in we've
sent the test case we sent it did this
in the last module we don't need to do
it again okay but we can check the
database so if we use Python manage.py
shell
in here
enter
just zoom it just invokes a
um a Django shell or python interpreter
for Django same as what you'd see
locally now what we can do here is we
can say
um from core dot models
import
contacts so we can say C equals contact
dot objects
dot last
and then C okay and Bobby stemming okay
that was the call we made in module two
module three sorry okay can you see
that's probably quite small I do
apologize
um it's just you can't change the font
size in Docker yet okay apparently so
there we have it that worked
um and that's it that's module four you
could directory configuration should
look like this on the screen if it's not
pause check go back make sure it does
before you move on to the next module
I'll see you in module five bye
okay module five
what have we got here we've got a back
end we've got steps that's everything
closed down so we're picking up exactly
where we left off in module four so
we're going to steps and module five
we'll open up this preview
um we're halfway through the course now
so it's probably a good time for me to
say look if you like this content
please visit did coding's YouTube
channel
um And subscribe and click the Bell
because you'll like other content that I
add and also drop a like on this actual
video on free code camp and uh comment
as well because I do get to see them
it's always good to have feedback so
start and end of these um Step by steps
just make sure the configuration on your
local machine matches what's on here if
not clone it down
we've built our core app we now need to
build an e-commerce app the e-commerce
app will be used to it'll have two
endpoints 11 items endpoint and an order
endpoint so we want users to be able to
call an endpoint and retrieve all the
items that we've got in our shop okay
and also call it same endpoint and pass
through a primary key to identify a
single item and then if they want to
purchase it
they place an order so there'll be an
order endpoint for that particular item
so on top of that we want to do some
validation so we want to make sure that
the item has stock
uh we want to also make sure that only
users that are authenticated can access
these endpoints so there's a few little
bits we're going to be looking at over
the next four modules we're going to add
token authentication to our app uh we're
going to build out some models some new
serializers we're going to add some
validation to the serializers and see
where it leaves us great stuff right so
let's use this command here in back end
if I close them down again
I will close the terminal down
completely because I'm using Docker now
remember
you can fire up Docker with Docker Dash
compose up dash dash dash build no yeah
that's right and that'll fire up this
app
um in Docker and when you're in there
you can then use these python commands
in the API
so we'll quit the shell
and we'll dump that in here yes we will
in the API and this is me making these
calls in Docker however you will see
them appear in my local machine and the
reason you'll see them on my local
machine is because the data persists and
we're using volumes so e-commerce is now
here
we need to change the rest
framework variable in settings the
reason being is because we are adding
token Authentication
what we've done here is we've had we've
added a default default authentication
class called
authentication.token authentication so
anywhere where we add a permissions
class in a view will enforce
authentication so you won't be able to
access that view
unless you pass through a valid token
okay so that's the first step
in fact
if we do drif token
education
this page here will walk you through all
of the steps but I'm doing that
um
for you so just follow the modules
so I've added that we now need to add a
new app into our installed apps so back
into settings go into our installed apps
save over and you can see now that we've
got authentication added there okay
stands to reason it will probably be
adding some URLs and making migrations
because we're getting new tables in the
database okay so let's go back back to
our URL conf
and you can see now we've got a new
endpoint
and we've got a new
oh I do apologize so we're in importing
from Django rest framework and we've got
a new endpoint save that so this means
now we've got an endpoint in our project
where when a user visits that endpoint
and passes through a username and a
password they will then receive back a
token that token acts as an
authentication token so if we receive
that then in the back end we know that
that token
um links to a certain user
okay
keep token safe
now we need to migrate those new tables
that we've added in installed apps to
our database so we go back in the docker
paste those pieces of code in there
and zoom in you can see now can you see
that we've got auth token we've got
initial Auto and token proxy which are
the migration files for the tables that
we're now having on the database don't
worry we'll see them in a Mac between
admin table very very soon
what we also need is something called a
signal now if you're familiar with uh
Django you'll know what these are
we want them a way of creating a token
every time a user is created in a
database the way we do that is we use a
signal now a single a piece of code
which
um
in Django we call a signal something
that receives a signal from a certain
table based on an action now that could
be a pre-saver or a post save so when it
when a database has a new instance saved
in it a signal is sent from the database
and this receiver is an antenna and it
picks up that signal and says Ah okay
I need to do something and in this case
it will be create a new token that's
what we're trying to do here
so we go into e-commerce we have a new
file called
signals.py sorry I'm not following the
models so the module five steps
um step by step I am going step by step
I'm not reading straight from the screen
so you can see we've got a post save
signal so after something saved we get a
signal we have a receiver to receive
said signal
um
what table the core user table so when a
user is added to the database that's who
sends the signal and what do we want to
create we want to take create a new
token which is the new table we've
created in our database and this is what
the code all looks like
we now need to wire that into the app so
when the app starts the signal is active
it's looking for signals
and what we do in here is we say def
ready so it's a ready method pass
through itself
what do we do we want to import from
uh e-commerce
dot signals
perfect
now when Ecommerce starts signals will
be active
that's what this bit here is what do we
want to do now
we want to create our first user we'll
make it create a super user so I want a
super user which is twofold that will
trigger that token so we'll have a token
and it'll also give me access to the
built-in admin page which I'll show you
in a second
so I'll copy
paste that in here can you see don't
necessarily need to see it but there you
go
enter and that will ask me for a
username just be Bobby don't worry about
an email address
just a random password there we go user
is created I'd expect to see a token in
the database
so go in your browser
we will go to localhost forward slash
admin because that's the URL The Sinner
Bobby
password perfect I expect to see Bobby
in a user table because that's my super
user if I look in tokens there we go
it's created a token and this is the key
so this is my authentication token
perfect
you go back into modules what we now
need to do is we need to test
the end point so I expect when I test
this endpoint I make this call using
HTTP or HTTP in the um in Docker I would
expect
to receive something like this which
would be an endpoint a response and it
will say token it will give me my new
token so what I'm going to do is take
most of this but you need obviously use
your own username and password so I'll
copy this
and I will go to the app container
remember we're making a call from app to
API go into CLI
drop that in there
and I will say my username is Bobby
password
equals
press enter
perfect
see that so it starts in eight at B
eight eight
we go back into the database afb88
perfect that's exactly why I wanted to
see
that's it we've just added what we are
module five which is added token
authentication to our project this
is really good stuff so now we can add
that to our views so if somebody's
trying to access information they will
only access information relative to that
user that's what we're able to do not
always the case you might just want to
have authentication on certain views so
that only authenticate or signed in
users can access it it's good if you
imagine you've got a mobile app which
you know is completely dis disconnected
from the back end okay same as a react
or view app
so where are we that's it that's module
five thank you very much for watching
I'll see you in module six
okay module six
um let's go ahead and begin like I said
I'm recording this in one foul sweep so
please excuse the cluttered uh left-hand
side so steps module six
in preview
we've built our core app configured
everything we've got a generous
framework working we've now got an
e-commerce app with token authentication
in this
module just make sure your configuration
by the way is exactly where it needs to
be on the left hand side it should look
like this it's not cloned down
what we're going to do now is we're
going to go through the same process we
went in the core app build our models
build our serializers build our views
build our URLs in that order okay
so remember models relate to databases
so we need an item and an order model
so
a model to catch
all the items in the database
so go into backend e-commerce models
drop them in there
and I'm not going to spend too much time
going through this but it's important
you understand some of the methods so
we've got an item model with some Fields
right we've got a stock and a price so
what stock we have in the database and
what the price is now price is in pens
and pounds or cents in dollars whatever
the case may be doesn't really matter
we've got a method to convert it into
remember a few and pounds and Pence if
you divide Pence about 100 you've got
your pounds you've got managed stocks
we've got a method to
um increase stock sorry decrease stock
by a factor of whatever the order is
okay and we've got another couple of
methods here to place an order
to check stocks so when you place an
order it checks the stock if there's
enough stock or it is in the stock
equals the order or is above the order
then it calls managed stock so that's
one of the validation methods we'll be
using in the serializer then we'll go on
order
model which will relate to the user so
foreign key to the user for the item
that's been ordered and the quantity
okay so then we'll have an end point to
view all of the user's orders okay all
of the items
retrieve a single item retrieve a single
order retrieve all of the orders so okay
that's all we're doing in the models
we now need a new file called
serializers Dot py
so I'm jumping forward there we go
eCommerce civilizer.py you now need to
pick up all of this code
copy and me comments
drop it in there and say
so we're bringing into two models we've
just created and then for very similar
to the core uh core app we're bringing
in serializers bringing in status and
exception the rigs are bringing in
exceptions because I've got this class
here which is called a not enough stock
exception in a normal app you'd probably
have a number file here called
exceptions and you'd have a whole bunch
of them so when you're validating you
can call invoke certain racer and
exceptions based on validation we're
only doing one piece of validation we're
checking that the stock is high enough
or we've got adequate stock to cover the
order that's coming in so if
when calling the method
check stock
is too low we will raise not enough
stock which is a 400 bad request the
details say there is not enough stock
and it'll be an invalid code okay
model serializer item serializer order
serializer is another model serializer
so these serializers again I spoke about
this in module two I believe there's a
whole bunch of different serializers you
don't need to use model serializers like
I said that points it to model fields
and it kind of does this um this clever
um model matching uh sorry field
matching you can use other sorts of
serializer it's just there's one called
just serializer in which case you need
to specify what those fields look like
um for this you know
outside of this course you might want to
do a deeper dive on that but we're using
models it stands to reason that we can
use a model serializer so this item
serializer has got no Fields we're not
adding any Fields class meta model item
and we've got it sorry title stock and
price okay there are three fields that
we have in the database
order serializer however we're using an
item primary key related field what
we're doing there is we are saying that
the item field in order serializer
remember that we're cleverly pointing
Fields towards model Fields we're saying
that that particular field identify it
by its primary key there's a foreign key
link between the two tables so we're
identifying that link via a primary key
I hope that makes sense
um same meta as as above but this time
we've got a validate method that
validate method would be called when we
call when we save the um sorry when we
call it is valid so the is valid method
we'll call validate and it will check to
make sure that all the information is as
expected now in this case what we're
trying to do is yeah check the fields
other fields okay bang on perfect after
that we then want to check the stock now
if the stock is too low
it would be
um
we will raise this not enough stock
exception so it'll be not valid does
that make sense so that's why we've got
this method in there it's being called
when we call the is valid method in the
serializer okay
then I've created a few models pop them
in the admin file here so we can access
them in a built-in admin page don't need
to go too further on that and we need to
migrate
those new tables to the database so we
open up Docker again open up the API
container sorry not the app one API
container
open CLI Bob them in there press enter
there we go we've created an item table
and an order table
we should be able to see those in here
we update
happy days we've got an items we've got
an order
actually let's go ahead and create some
items shall we add an item
first one
first one
we'll have a stock of 10 price
300.
saving out another
that's two
that's two
stock of 20 price 500 that'd be five
pounds right okay we've now got items in
the database so when we do call the
endpoint we should see something
and that is it that is the end of module
six so the next module will start adding
the views and the the routers the module
after that we'll add some tests and we
should have a fully functioning app at
the end of that so thank you very much
for watching make sure your root
directory is what it needs to look like
before you move on to the next module
I'll see you in module 7.
okay module seven here we are so two
more modules including this one
there we go module seven look at this in
preview
make sure your configuration on the left
hand side matches this if you don't
clone down
okay our e-commerce app is picking up
speed we've got our models we've got a
serializer we now need to wire it into
some views so we need to pick up all of
this code
I'm going to drop this
into back end e-commerce views
paste
what are we doing different to what we
did in core
this we're bringing in is authenticated
remember with wired in token
authentication so by bringing this in
and adding this to our views that will
invoke the authentication class that we
have in our settings which is token
authentication we're expecting a token
to be sent via the request in the header
as
um authorization
Authentication
so we've got an items View
we've got some mix-ins here as well
actually so um good thing about this is
a generic view set okay so we've had an
API view we're now using a generic view
set it's generic view set has built-in
methods such as retrieve
uh what are they retrieve
um
list create update I forgot what they
all are now
um but by using these uh the generic
view set and some mix-ins you get very
very similar to the generic views in
Django actually a lot of the methods are
all built in you don't need to do a lot
of heavy lifting especially when we're
working with model
um serializers okay you can see good
example of this this is the item view
okay we've got no methods we're just
passing through permissions telling it
what query set is we're telling what
serialized to use
by using those mix-ins I've got a list
endpoint
and it doesn't show all and I've got a
show and retrieve so it's a get request
for a single item okay so we pass
through the uuid or the ID of an item
you're retrieving one very powerful
next we've got an orders view set here
similar passing through everything and
I'm a member of actually that's probably
a hangout so we're using the list and
retrieve to get single orders okay we're
using this update one which I'm I don't
think I'm actually using we've probably
got access to that view that a URL
because that's what we're doing here the
view set the generic view set will give
you access to methods but it also
construct those endpoints for you as
well
um
on a API view you need to add the as
view method when you're wiring up the
Euro the URL router but with a generic
view set you do it slightly different
I'll show you in a second difference
here is again permission to class we've
got a create method here so this is what
we're going to be calling when we create
an order
different Decor is we're passing through
to the serializer the data okay if the
serializer is valid so we're going to
call that is there enough stock if there
is enough stock we're not saving the
serializer because this is a model
serializer link to an order we're not
creating
um
we we have to place in all we're calling
a place order method it's so we're not
necessarily just saving a serializer
we're doing a slightly different we're
calling a method in a model so we're
getting the item specific item based on
a PK the primary key and then we're
calling the order place order method
which will create that order in the
database and then we respond with the or
we pass through the New Order that we've
created so the order serializer and the
data so that's how we're sending the
data back to the user okay that's the
views very simple right
we now need a router go back into models
we're doing all of this in url conf so
we copy this go into drf
thereof course going to eurocomp and
we're going to add some bits okay what
we're doing we're bringing in the views
from e-commerce and then we're wiring up
these generic view sets different to the
API view okay we're called we're putting
as view here same as a class based
viewing Django very similar API view
these are definitely these are generic
view sets
um so we're using uh regex so it's a
regular expression URL
um
e-commerce views so this is the view set
itself remember next we haven't got as
View at the end there
base name is item and Order and then
what we do we're registering those to
the router
the URL patterns become your the URLs
from the router remember so
although we're registering things to
root up because we're using generic
um view sets and a whole bunch of other
stuff that router has a whole bunch of
um
urls
so we'll have a retrieve and a list and
a get with a PK that are already built
in just by registering this so the URL
patterns becomes vast and then what we
do is we append these three URLs to the
URL patterns and that becomes a whole
bunch of Euro patterns for the project
okay
that's that that's module seven we are
good to go the reason I've stopped today
is because we're going to be tuned
testing in module eight it's the last
piece we'll be doing some unit testing
and then we'll be testing those
endpoints okay so that just make sure
that your configuration is looking how
mine does or looking it does in the
modules and you'll be good to go thank
you very much for watching module 8 next
Perfect Right module eighth
module eight let me close some stuff
open up module a
good before we start make sure your
configuration is exactly the same if not
playing down from GitHub let's move on
to the steps
so like module 4 when we're done the
testing for our core app let's do it
again for e-commerce
except this is a little bit more
complicated
doesn't need to be any more complicated
I won't go into a big deep dive because
I've already spoken about the API client
in test cases so we're creating a client
there's a cordable very much like the
request package
um so we're calling the the API testing
and adding it to a test database
inheriting the API test case here so we
have a setup method we're creating some
dummy information similar to what I did
in the admin page earlier adding five
items
we're creating self items variable here
which is all of the items in a database
we're creating a user well we know when
we create a user we're also creating a
token
we're creating a couple of orders okay
against the first item
a way we can call the order at endpoint
uh token so creating a token we know
that we've just created it yeah so it's
self token is for this user here and
then the client is API clone
and then difference here is that on self
client we can call the credentials
method and pass through the token so
we'll add a header to each and every
call remember with part we've got
permissions class in these views so if
we don't have this we're going to hit a
failure each time so we're passing
through the token so how it will be
written it'll be token space
so it'll be it'll say authorization and
it will say token space and it will be
the token key okay and that being a
header every call and then we have how
many well we got here
we've got a few
way two four six eight ten Tanish
ten test cases so what we're doing we
are
um checking out what's in the database
we're expecting five
if there is Happy Days we've got um we
make a call to the item endpoint
remember we've got a retrieve list or a
list method that'll bring back every
item so we're making a call to it we're
expecting a status 200. that's the first
endpoint
now we want to get
each item so what we're doing we're
going to cycle through all of the items
and then we're going to make five calls
to the end point you can do this
differently but this is just one way of
doing it so I'm calling the endpoint
five times and I'm saying right get the
item with PK from the item from the
database so item.id
we're expecting a 200 because we know
they're there right so we're getting a
response 200.
then we get
then we get a little bit complicated so
test order is more than stock so we're
now calling methods right so
um
for items so these are methods in the
item database so current stock
is
um so again the current stock and then
we're saying I check stock so we're
passing through so make check that the
order is more than stock so we'd expect
that to be false
we go through I'm not going to go
through each of these but I'm basically
testing every outcome for the endpoint
so have we got too much stock we've not
got enough stock does the stock equal
the order
um what happens if we
um don't send
um
an item id something along those lines
okay so I'm just going through I mean
you could probably be a lot more um
thorough than this but these are the
texts that we've got
modulate okay so we can now go in here
go into docker
I'm in API which is correct
move that up there
drop
test manage.py test in there we're now
18 to 18 Core 10 in e-commerce I'm
expecting there we go okay all the tests
work this is where you want to be
now let's go ahead and test some
endpoints I need module 8 opened and
this is how you'll probably need to do
it as well so I'll open up modulate
without it being in
preview mode the reason being is because
every place it says
your name I'm gonna control h and change
it to
the username of the person in the
database I know it's Bobby
can change it I'm going to change your
password whenever you see your password
I'm going to change that to
my password
so what we're doing now I'm just
creating the HTTP endpoints your token
every time I see your token I'm going to
change that to
the token in the database which is
this one here copy
and change all the loads
and then you've got
um uuid for item so you can see here
we're calling the item endpoint so your
uuid will be an ID that appears in the
database so we go into items
change this one copy
I'll change that one
oh sorry
it's where it gets a little bit
difficult when you're
just doing a
bike and then we get onto after we get
onto orders so we won't won't look at
those yet okay cool so we go back in
preview I should now have those yeah we
do right so
spend some time going through these so
let's test all the endpoints that so
call our endpoints here are the requests
we can make to our new endpoint so we've
got
first
what I do
I'm gonna keep going backwards and
forwards but we go to the app container
going to CLI and what we do we will drop
this in there so we're calling the API
auth to get a token
there we go token it works
I'm going to zoom in each time I know
it's small I do apologize but at least
you've got instructions
you've got the code
next we want to
um check
and get all of the items remember this
is the domain the endpoint is item that
is a retrieve all we're getting all
items in a database providing we send
through the token
um back into Docker drop it in there and
I expect to see two items we've got two
in the database
now what happens if I remove the header
with the authentication token
there you go not authenticated
perfect that's exactly what we want to
see
next
we want to retrieve one item that we
have in the database
foreign
there we go pass through the uid
and it gets a single retrieves one item
what else we got this got uh retrieve
all orders
and yeah we can look at that one
back to Docker retrieve all orders we've
got two I haven't got any orders in a
database okay let's make an order shall
we
um your uuid Authentication
um
this will place an order for item id
sorry I'm I'm
moving around on this I probably should
have looked right so if I change
that this will retrieve all orders this
will
retrieve a single item this will place
an order for an item
so let's place an order for an item
shall we
foreign
not handy when you're making a video so
what is this doing so we call in HTTP
we're calling the order endpoint we're
passing through an authentication token
and then we'll create an adjacent uh
data type and we're sending through the
ID of the item and a quantity I know
that we've got the stock of one
let's copy that
and we'll drop that in here
that will create an order if I do that
again
and change the quantity to 1000
I know we don't have a stock of a
thousand that should say there is not
enough stock remember we're validating
that
and if there's not enough stock we're
raising an exception brilliant so now we
can call the
see any trouble with Docker you can't
press up and get your previous let's
check all orders and then I won't keep
you on here any longer because you can
do this in your own time so we should
now see one order right
there we go brilliant that's exactly
what I wanted to see just zoom in we
added an order of one remember and
retrieved it
and let me also showed you
where is it where is it where is it
there we go
so what I'll do I'll create another
order just quickly
and I'll create that with five
I believe I've got enough stock
there is
we will then get all of our orders
with this one here copy
back in the docker drop it now should
now have two perfect that's exactly what
I wanted to see
that is it
that is the end of the course let's just
recap quickly what have we done we have
had we've gone through eight modules
first two modules were all about getting
the code configuring a Django project
essentially nice and easy stuff
um we have then created a core app with
a contact endpoint
the normal model serializer and we've
just got a post request we're using an
API view which is similar to a Django
Class View
brilliant we've then invoked or added
token authentication to the project
created an e-commerce app with an item
and an order endpoint with permission
classes so only those that have got an
authentication approval can view
retrieve create information so we have
now created a very very good
um not production ready API
um but it's a good API that you can use
and hopefully refactor and use it in
your own project now
I'd just like to thank everyone for
watching
um if you like this content then please
visit did coding and you'll see many
more videos like this on my channel like
this video on freecodecamp and add a
comment because I do get to see those
comments and comments from previous
courses on freeco Camp really has led to
me building some other courses and
tutorials so um just before I do close
the video out I just would like to thank
free code cam one more time just for
allowing me to create this course and
for them to post it on their Channel
keep up the good work keep that free
content coming again thank you very much
and hopefully I'll be seeing you very
very soon bye
foreign
[Music]